il ya quelques jours je vous présentais
cette toute nouvelle machine que j'avais
reçue c'est le nouvel imac de 2020 imac
27 pouces écran nano textures et enfin
belle bête de compet
et aujourd'hui il est temps de donner
mon retour après quelques temps
d'utilisation pour vous dire réellement
ce que j'en pense avant toute chose il
ya deux trois prix rock et qu'il faut
connaître la première chose c'est que
c'est la première fois que j'utilise un
imac je n'ai jamais travaillé sur un
autre format que macbook pro 13 pouces
depuis quelques mois un macbook pro 15
pouces
avant il ya eu a bien bien bien avant la
machine qui est accrochée là bas
derrière si vous connaissez le studio
vous le savez donc j'ai bossé depuis
très longtemps avec des portables
d'apple mais jamais avec le format
ordinateurs de bureau et encore moins
avec le format tout en n'en commet pas
où trouver ici sur la dreamhack
donc pour moi c'est une vraie découverte
donc j'ai plus vous donnez mon retour en
terme d'utilisation sur cette typologie
de produits vous expliquer comment je
les prends en main comment je n'utilise
qu'est-ce que ça m'apporte réellement
comme bénéfice par rapport à un
ordinateur portable macbook pro 16
pouces mais également comment est ce que
je perçois le vert nano texturé et vous
donner d'un point de vue global mon
ressenti par rapport à ce produit pour
vous dire si oui ou non en 2020 et même
pourquoi pas en début 2021 même coup
randonnée 2021 est ce que ce produit
vaut qu est ce qui l'intéresse en
cassant ses forces
quelles sont ses faiblesses et surtout
est-ce qu'il est fait pour vous mais
avant toute chose et si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas j'habite à venir vous
abonner votre question petit bouton
rouge qui sait tout juste ici en dessous
parce que je vous parle bien évidement
d'ordinateurs d'apple par l'ordinateur
d'autres mal je vous parle de mondes
connectés je vous parle de smartphones
et je vous parle de vous de votre vie
numérique
donc je vous invite à venir vous abonner
activer la cloche pour tout savoir des
qu'une prochaine vidéo arrivera c'est
une vidéo aujourd'hui qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec intego intego c'est une
marque nous propose une solution pour
venir protéger vos mac mais également
depuis peu vos pc intego existe depuis
1997 et là je propose une solution qui
s'appelle mac internet security x9 qui
veut regrouper deux outils principaux
pour vos mac un premier temps un
antivirus et le deuxième c'est un
pare-feu ya plus en plus de malwares qui
circulent et rien que cet été intego
découvert de nouvelles attaques
virusbarrier x5 viennent on protéger
votre mac contre toutes les attaques
connues pouvez bénéficier des dernières
mises à jour de base
antiviral et venir se caler votre
ordinateur pour savoir si tout est ok et
lorsque vous venez brancher un iphone un
ipad ou un ipod et bien votre antivirus
vallée scanner pour savoir s'il n'y a
pas un logiciel malveillant à
l'intérieur vous voyez votre ordinateur
votre disque dur qui est protégé votre
quarantaine si vous en avez s'il y en a
pas vos fichiers de confiance vous
pouvez planifier des analyses autres
logiciels et pas des moindres saynètes
barrière x9 c'est un pare-feu là où
votre mac va venir vous protéger des
connexions entrantes mais barrière x9 va
vous protéger des connexions entrantes
mais également des connexions sortantes
il vous demandera donc les permissions
pour tous les logiciels qui veulent se
connecter à internet
mais toutes les collections qui rentrent
ici elles sont bloquées les collections
sortant que vous donnez uniquement des
autorisations aux logiciels que vous
souhaitez bon tout ça c'est en local sa
fonction ya pas de soucis vous
choisissez de bloquer désactiver peut
choisir des exceptions et vous avez
plusieurs profils un profil pour votre
domicile un profil pour votre travail
également un profil d'accès public est
derrière vous voyez toutes les
applications notamment plication qui
sont sortante entrantes vous savez tous
voulaient d'autoriser vous les autoriser
pas comme je le disais également une
version pour pc qui existent vous avez
une remise de 50% pour tout savoir
répondre à protéger votre mac mais
également à votre pc je vous ai mis les
liens en bas dans la description aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil parce que
acheter une belle machine comme ça c'est
bien mais pas la protéger des croisés
voyez vraiment faire attention pour moi
le premier point positif que j'ai avec
ce format d'ordinateurs là c'est que
bien qu'on a un écran de 27 pouces et
bien malgré tout il prend pas
particulièrement de place et ça chauffe
ça vraiment génial pourquoi parce que
vous avez votre ordinateur qui prend
juste cette place-là ici il n'y a pas
d'unité centrale tout est à l'intérieur
vous avez un pied qui est franchement
design même si effectivement on est sur
un design qui est déjà connu et reconnu
c'est pas tout nouveau mais ça
fonctionne toujours très bien ici en
plus votre clavier votre trackpad et
votre souris sont sans fil bien qu'on
est donc un écran 27 pouces et bien
l'encombrement reste malgré tout
minimale et je puis vous assurer que ça
ça fait vraiment la différence et c'est
un des éléments pour lequel je vais
vraiment venir aimé cette machine je la
pose au fond de mon bureau
et lorsque je n'utilise pas que c'est
sur mon macbook projet car retirer ces
éléments là il profite toujours de la
place sur mon bureau ça m'évite d'avoir
décapiterait de tous les côtés enfin
voila je me sens vraiment extrêmement
pratique alors ça c'est pas tout nouveau
chez apple mais pour moi c'est nouveau
et chaud ça vraiment bien alors il ya un
point que j'adore et ça c'est le
deuxième point
ça va être la calibration l'écran je
suis pas infographiste mais par contre
le point qui m'intéresse c'est
l'étalonnage pour le montage des vidéos
et ça c'est vraiment important
je trouve que si on a un écran qui est
extrêmement bien calibré extrêmement
beau globalement et le point peu
négative de trous tonnes dans mon
travail c'est que ça va venir je lire un
petit peu donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est
tout bête je vais dans mes paramètres
d'affichage moniteurs et lorsque je
décide de travailler de faire du montage
et les talaud eh bien voyez hop je
désactive trou tonnes je décoche la
casse mais a contrario lorsque je vais
venir faire de la bureautique je suis
sur les factures que je suis issu aura
plein d'autres choses où sont mes emails
et bien sûr sa pratique parce que ça
repose les yeux qui regardent et aju
montrent l'intérêt d'avoir envers la
texture est ici voudra donc notre écran
vous le voyez ici on a un éclairage qui
pète eh bien regardez je vais essayer de
retrouver un peu l'éclairage qu'on le
voit qu'on devine les durs à trouver à
la il est là là on le voit là la par là
on a le reflet l'éclairage et c'est tout
l'intérêt de ce canal aux textures et
est bien c'est que ça vient vraiment
vous protéger des reflets vous avoir sur
des baies vitrées sur des lumières
derrière vous et ça croyez moi c'est
vachement bien moins chez moi j'en avais
pas nécessairement besoin parce que j'ai
pas de sources de lumière derrière moi
je n'ai plus tôt et de l'autre côté avec
une fenêtre avant de venir coacher cette
option vous revenir le prendre
réfléchissez vraiment est-ce que vous en
avez besoin oui ou non parce que ça
vient significativement augmenté quand
même la facture mais au-delà de ça et
vous le voyez ici quelque chose qui
marche bien qui est assez bluffant et
qui justifie quand même mais la
différence de prix le troisième point
que je trouvais vraiment pratique ce
sont les ports alors les ports vous
direz si elle pas forcément quelque
chose de vraiment exceptionnel mais
l'idée d'avoir encore ces quatre ports
usb à ça c'est vachement bien j'ai pas
mal de disque dur de sauvegarde en ssd
qui sont ennuyeuses il ya donc ça c'est
pratique j'ai également des disques de
stockage en usb c'est thunderball 3 ça
c'est super et ça c'est vraiment bien et
notamment pour toutes les questions de
tarifs liées au stockage ça je vous
donne en quelques instants photo mois
qu'il ya des charges et des cartes sd
bien voyez je peux faire directement ici
ça c'est extrêmement pratique alors
j'utilise un petit peu moins la prise
casque
moi je suis en wifi dont j'utilise pas
la prise ethernet donc le fait de voir
toute cette collecte est disponible pour
moi c'est vraiment gros plus alors un
autre truc qui est vachement
intéressante et plan qui sera moi je
n'ai pas fait si vous pouvez venir grid
et votre ram
vous avez deux flottes de prix pourrait
monter de ce lot de plus mais une fois
de plus si apple ça coûte tout de suite
très très cher parce qu'il faut le
savoir chez apple vous avez une config
de vases un tarif de base pour jonathan
reste quand même un peu cher mais pas
excessivement cher vu ce qu'on peut
faire et vu la qualité vu le
positionnement du produit par rapport à
la gamme complète que vous avez chez
apple mais par contre si toute une vie
vécue stomisés monter la ram si vous
voulez passer par exemple vous avez
drame de base voulait monter un 16-1 32
ou 1 128 pourquoi pas bon minimum 32
pour la vidéo c'est je pense qu'il me
faudrait mais si je vous envisager
l'avenir donc j'ai besoin de beaucoup
beaucoup de fluidité 128 sap est
pourquoi pas envisageable tout de suite
ça va vous coûter extrêmement cher
autant on peut dire pour l'instant je
porte cette config là et en fonction de
ce que je voudrais un peu plus tard et
bien je peux regretter il ya un côté un
peu rassurant et pratique donc pourquoi
pas mais pour le stockage par contre je
peux pas du tout venir le regretter plus
tard parce que vous avez la puce t2 qui
est là pour la sécurité
votre ssd il est lié à votre puce télé
donc c'est strictement impossible de
venir ajoutent un ssd retard donc vous
choisissez dès le départ que vous allez
venir acheter votre capacité de stockage
est tout de suite si vous voulez
l'augmenter ça coûte relativement cher
donc vous pouvez me dire à m derrière
sur la prise thunderbolt roi un ssd
autant si bien de pouvoir avoir un dix
contre onze de temps en temps pour faire
du backup l'idée d'avoir un ordinateur
là c'est d'avoir quelque chose de très
léger de très design complètement
dégagée de toute contrainte et si vous
mettez des ssd derrière à permanente
pour ça un peu un peu dommage
l'autre point que j'adore et je trouve
vraiment pratique c'est le fait d'avoir
le choix j'ai un clavier qui est
extrêmement pratique on pourrait
l'imaginer un peu plus profilé pour au
moins fatiguer les poignées bon voila
moi j'ai vraiment eu absolument aucun
souci là dessus et ce tous que ça m'a
vraiment bien j'aime beaucoup l'idée
d'avoir un très gros trackpad comme ça
en complément de la souris peut vraiment
tenir l'utiliser comme je veux en
fonction des projets sur lesquels je
travaille pour un côté un peu
professionnelle font ça vraiment bien
pour un côté bureautique la souris rats
très très bien mais voyez pour du
montage pour certaines applications je
trouve que l'idée d'avoir ce trackpad en
plus c'est vraiment extrêmement mal hein
et puis surtout le fait de tout avoir
connecté sans aucun fil ça me permet de
positionner comme je veux à droite à
gauche de le déplacer de le prendre leur
pause et de le dégager de faire ce que
je veux comme je veux avec beaucoup de
modularité et c'est vraiment ce que je
viens et mais ici alors ce que j'aime en
plus sur la souris et bien c'est fait de
pouvoir inscrire les très très
facilement enfin que tu as des choses
qui sont pas nouvelles nouvelles mais
qui pour moi en tout cas qu'ils
découvrent ce produit de cette manière
là et pour voir que c'est pas tout
nouveau ça reste très actuelle est très
accessible donc ça fait cette machine un
outil qu'est vraiment parfait pour la
productivité qu'elles soient familiales
qu'elles soient professionnelles et si
vous avez ce professionnel réfléchissez
une fois de plus vraiment bien à la
confie qu'il vous faudra parce que voilà
arrive un moment mais notamment sur le
ssd apple c'est cher mais on en a pour
son argent ici petit bémol il faut
vraiment que je précise mais c'est lié
il
si à ma table qui est une table en verre
je vais devoir utiliser ma souris avec
une petite feuille blanche sans quoi ça
ne marchera pas de petits tapis de
souris mais si je le pose sur n'importe
quel support et sur le bus rouge sur
lequel je l'utilisais ces derniers jours
et bien je n'ai absolument aucun
problème mais ici malheureusement
eh bien voyez si je n'ai pas de petit
tapis de souris ça ne marche pas bon
d'avoir une femme plus assez dupe en
détail par contre le clavier extrêmement
confortable bon pour ne touche pour
bosser dessus c'est vraiment très très
cool ça va être la même chose au niveau
du trackpad très précis pour différents
mouvements un doigt de doigts trois
doigts ça marche très très bien la
souris aussi cool et je vais pouvoir
bien navigué comme ça avec vos deux doit
faire défiler ses pratiques soit 8 x ça
marche bien c'est un vrai régal
un projet comme celui là vous allez
choisir la configuration qui vous
intéressent en fonction vos visages
alors moi je peux vous décrire mésusage
à moi qui sont pas forcément les vôtres
mais en tout cas ce que je trouve
intéressant avec une machine comme celle
là c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
polyvalence donc en fonction de ce que
vous allez souhaité faire et de votre
usage professionnel familial pourquoi
pas les deux à la maison
eh bien vous avez pas forcément utilisés
de la même manière moi j'utilise
beaucoup en faisant du montage
regardez par exemple
chez moi tout cas plus importants tout
de suite c'est le confort de visionnage
je parle d'un écran 16 pouces qui est
très cool a dû 27 pouces typiquement jeu
sans faille un que de profs un accueil
prochain logiciel qui aujourd'hui édité
par apple et qui marche merveilleusement
bien et qui est complètement adapté qui
vient utiliser votre carte graphique
vient utiliser votre processeur des
façons complètement optimale et qui
fonctionnera très très bien avec cette
machine donc pour mon usage moi en tout
cas là dessus c'est cool ça marche bien
c'est pratique pour me réalisés tous mes
tests je suis vraiment satisfait donc ça
c'est le premier usage c'est la vidéo
chez moi mais le deuxième gros gros
usages et bien ça va être pour le
travail de mes photos de mes miniature
que ce soit pour instagram que ce soit
pour évidemment youtube et voyait
typiquement essais pour venir à bosser
sur en laye trop retouchées contre haas
couleurs et compagnie je me fais tourner
un photoshop dessus en même temps cet
imac ira très bien pour faire tourner de
nombreux jeux mais moi je ne suis pas
gamer donc je n'ai pas testé avec des
jeux et la question se pose aussi pour
le rendu 3d une fois de plus c'est pas
des choses que je fais c'est pas dans
les usages pour c'est pas moi qui ai
vraiment pas vous éclairer là dessus
mais choisissez vraiment votre
configuration mais moi pour mes usages
c'est une machine qui est performante
qui marche très bien et avec laquelle
j'ai vraiment apprécié travailler en
complément de mon macbook pro 13 pouces
il ya notre plan qui est important ici
c'est vous savez notamment que
télétravail avec le confinement qui ait
lieu et beaucoup de personnes qui
continuent à télétravailler bien c'est
le fait d'avoir ici une webcam en 1080p
donc ça c'est cool et le fait aussi
d'avoir un son de qualité avec des
micros studio alors on n'a pas à avoir
des micros non plus qui vont
complètement être absolument incroyable
pour l'idée du travail à domicile je
fais tout petit sur le lay back à 27 est
absolument pas avec un bernard dumont
micro externe
on fait tout dans la machine sera mais
d'avoir un rendu qui est convenable
il ya vraiment un gros focus qui fait
sur le visage alors ici j'ai les
éclairages qui tape un petit peu voyez
ça vient s'adapter vraiment ici là un
appeau ça tient compte de ce côté là
mais également de ce côté là pour qu'on
me voit bien sûr jeunes dont six de
babar en regrets sur ce produit là ça
serait de ne pas avoir failli saïdi j'ai
une caméra en 1080p qui marche bien mais
pourquoi ne pas répliquer technologie
qu'on a dans les iphone failli samedi
pour venir déverrouiller extrêmement
facilement mais en tout cas ce que
j'aime par contre vraiment mais vraiment
avec cet ordinateur l'asse joue d'une
fois de plus le format la légèreté
malgré tout du produit
la polyvalence la robustesse et un
ordinateur qui sont à la robustesse a
plané vous le mettez comme vous voulez
en fonction de vous
votre s'étonne chez vous ça vraiment
bien vous n'allez pas avoir de câbles
apparents moi qui suis le roi pour
laisser des cartes de tous les côtés qui
fait pas attention à ça je ne suis pas
du tout un champion là-dedans eh bien
voyez là les choses qui est extrêmement
épuré c'est une machine que j'aime bien
leur s'est tout de suite un produit qui
peut coûter un petit peu cher on arrive
dans les 2000 et quelques euros pour
commencer à avoir un imac 27 pouces de
2020 si on veut regarder un peu plus
loin et se projeter dans les cinq dix
années à venir en fonction de nos
usagers de nos besoins et bien il faut
forcément monter sa config tamment au
niveau de l'art a essayé d'anticiper vos
besoins en termes de stockage
regardez également au niveau du
processeur au niveau de la carte
graphique j'ai déjà détaillé tout ça
dans ma vidéo de prise en main de
découverte de ce produit là la question
à se poser est donc quels sont vos
usages actuels quels seront vos usages
de demain est ce que vous le voulez chez
vous pour de la bureautique domestique
parce que même pour regarder des films
des séries c'est hyper confort et la
qualité audio est vraiment là donc c'est
super bien en complément de tout ce qui
va être bureautique familiale mais si
vous en avez un usage professionnel
dites vous bien que généralement les
tailles de fichiers viennent toujours à
augmenter comme moi en faisant de la
vidéo aujourd'hui en 4k probablement
pour quelques années en 8k donc faut
vraiment venir anticipé sa anticiper vos
besoins en termes de ram anticipé pas
mal de choses donc là aujourd'hui on est
sur la table d'un génération qui aura
lieu sur intel on arrivera je pense sur
la nouvelle version de l'imac et d'ici
quelques années sur un imac avec l'apple
silicone mais ça c'est pour plus tard
donc si vous voulez vraiment une machine
robuste qui sont encore avec les
solutions d' intel et bien vous pouvez
aller cet imac 27 pouces de 2020 moi
personnellement je trouve vraiment bien
et je réfléchis je réfléchis pourquoi
pas comment prendre un dans mon set up
en tout cas cette typologie sous format
d'ordinateurs en complément normal nos
process pousse à vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
aux commentaires est ce que vous pensez
cette machine là pourrait être faite
pour vous est-ce que vous avez franchi
le cap et si vous l'avez pas encore
franchi ce seuil est à l'infection sur
quelle configuration
est ce que vous pensez potentiellement
allait marquer moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire d'une se trouve extrêmement
rapidement pour continuer par les tec
pour continuer parler d'apple parce
qu'en cette période toujours belles
choses qui arrivent a très vite des
bisous kalt chacun
[Musique]